a new book pulls back the curtain on the
cia and it's often secret of directors
author chris whipple spoke to almost
every living director for his book the
spymasters
how the cici directors shape history
and the future it's published by
scribner an imprint of simon
schuster which is a division of viacom
cbs chris whipple
good morning thanks for being with us
good to be with you
what did you learn in in all of your
conversations and i have to say i was
incredibly envious of the ability to
talk to all these really interesting
people and what they've learned over the
years
what did you learn about the importance
of the relationship between the cia
director and the president of the united
states
well the first thing i learned anthony
is that when
you know in the when you go back through
the history of these directors and
interview almost every living cia
director
you discover that it's almost impossible
to overstate the
significance of the position i mean the
cia director is the person we depend
on to prevent another 911 or lethal
pandemic
and it's also this almost impossible
balancing act for
for the director you have to tell the
president hard truths
and at the same time you have to have
his ear
so the cia director commands an army of
analysts covert operatives paramilitary
warriors and
lethal drones but if he doesn't have the
ear of the president
the whole enterprise is for naught
that's difficult in the best of times
it may be almost impossible with this
president you say that
president trump ignoring warnings of a
pandemic
was worse than president bush's refusal
to listen to warnings ahead of 9 11. why
do you say that
well look at the results look at the
numbers uh look at the
the catastrophe that we're dealing with
right now
that is a result of a president who
ignored warnings that were in his
presidential brief
uh throughout january and in my book i
have a chapter on
president trump and his two directors
mike pompeo and gina haspel and also an
epilogue that
explains what the president knew and
when he knew it and what the
intelligence community told him
and among other things there was an
almost total breakdown of the
presidential briefing process in january
where he was having literally one verbal
briefing
a week now if you talk to any previous
president they'll tell you that's that's
almost a dereliction of duty
chris the the president has said that
that the cia told him the virus was not
a big deal
that's not what you heard well you know
you know you know
it was interesting because he said on
fox news
in effect he threw his intelligence
briefer beth center under the bus
he said that she downplayed the virus
now i think that's a case where
a competent c.i.a director
would either come to that briefer's
defense
or at least brief reporters on whether
or not
she did in fact warn him about the
coronavirus
that statement by trump was wrong on so
many levels
and it points to uh one of the
disappointments about the current
director gina haspel who
came in with really high hopes uh she is
a fascinating character
a mystery woman who flies under the
radar is given no interviews but i have
some stories about her when she was at
the black site the infamous cia black
site in thailand
uh where she struck up an interesting
rapport with one of the key al qaeda
terrorists
uh she's a fascinating story chris tony
decopol here since you mentioned the
president uh threw
an analyst under the bus as you put it
it brings to mind the other clashes he's
had in public with the intelligence
community
what impact do those clashes have on the
work of the cia
well the cia is pretty good at keeping
its head down
and ignoring who the president may be at
any given time in the white house but
there's no question about it i mean this
has been a broken marriage from day one
you remember when
the president went to langley and stood
in front of the most hallowed ground
at cia headquarters the memorial wall
and he bragged about the size of his
inauguration
and barely acknowledged the fallen cia
officers
it's been pretty rough ever since
but it's not the first time that a
president has thought that the cia was a
deep state
full of liberal enemies who were out to
bring him down that's what richard nixon
thought about
dick helms who was an iconic director
back in the 60s
and he's also a fascinating story in the
book yeah and as
chris whipple thank you as we pointed
out that you spoke to every living
director
except uh mike pompeo and gina haspel
who
were ci directors under president trump
thanks so much for being with us the spy
masters
goes on sale tomorrow and you can hear
chris whipple talk more about the
spymasters with cbs news chief justice
and homeland security correspondent jeff
begues on today's
cbs this morning podcast